foreign
howdy everybody
um I think people should be joining now
I'm just going to be taking a few
moments to allow people to be joining
the event and set up introductions for
folks so if you bear with me for a few
moments
why so see people are joining right now
so uh hello and welcome welcome to
another
um open source chat the first time
branded as posit open source chat two
weeks ago we had Rich
um for the talking about GT for the our
studio open source chat and now we're in
fully into the deposit World
um first off setting things up you know
what's the goal for today there's kind
of two big goals for these open source
chats
um firstly is to just connect users of a
tool of an open source tool in
particular
um to the people who develop the tool so
in this case uh Greg
um developers like Greg could sometimes
feel a little disconnected from end
users and from other people who are
developing on top of it and then users
are often unaware of how these tools get
made get maintained fix bugs uh you know
add additional functionality that sort
of thing uh and then open source
software just generally works better the
more active and the more engaged the
community is the better the connection
is there there between developers and
the users the better the software
uh and then secondly this is an
opportunity for each of you all to share
with each other uh how you use the tools
how you approach common problems with
those tools that sort of thing
um and then thirdly I should mention
another little goal of mine you know
this is a kind of the second pilot of
Open Source chat so I am kind of keen to
hear your guys's feedback on uh format
and how to structure these events to get
the most value for you uh is as well uh
if you remember two weeks ago with Rich
we use zoom for example which offered
like a nice discussion uh today we're
using restream uh which allows us to
stream live to YouTube as well as to to
LinkedIn just live uh so we're kind of
curious you know which of these tools or
maybe there's a third better tool is a
better way to to execute on the goal for
open source chat so definitely love to
hear from you you could reach out to me
personally Curtis Hitler on LinkedIn or
email at Curtis posit.com
okay so with that in mind
um a few set up uh things to set up
first
um we have a Greg and I have a few kind
of uh questions sort of set things up
for the full hour
um and Grinch to prepare a few demos to
kind of talk about some interesting
things with reactable
um but we would like you to ask your own
questions uh which you could do so in
chat
um and then we've also set up this slido
link with deposit dot excuse me POS dot
i t slash OS chat the links in the the
uh the URL to the link is in the um is
it a caption on the screen right there
if you want to ask things anonymously uh
and then Greg was also Keen to hear from
you he'd set up a kind of a seating
question which is
um this question uh what challenges uh
have you or your team been running into
related to GT and two reactables if that
um I'd be kind of keen to hear hear from
you about so there's a there's sort of
this kind of poll and then there's also
a uh a way to ask anonymous questions as
well so definitely Keen to hear from you
there
um great so to set things up for Greg
um a few things uh so Greg Lin is is a
you know member of our studio posits uh
Team he works actually on the package
manager team which is one of our
professional products uh and then he's
also the reactable uh maintainer
um the reactable r package helps you
create interactive data tables for R and
it's based on the react table JavaScript
library uh made with uh react R uh
package which connects the react
JavaScript library to our uh in this
open source chat we'll dive into
reactables development roadmap uh and of
course Greg is happy to filled your
questions comments and feedbacks about
reactable and about uh his work
um so yeah if you work with reactable
already if you have feedback uh if
you're struggling with things uh you
know struggling to create tables you
need for your work if you have a lot of
things to share uh regarding reactable
uh with the rest of community this event
is absolutely for you and then one other
mention before I introduce uh bring Greg
in is uh there's actually going right
going on right now as the table contest
and reactable is either the number one
or the number two package
um that gets relied upon for the table
for table contest entries the table
contest is scheduled to end on I think
the 15th of November uh I think it
actually might be the Friday like the
18th um but yeah so the deadline for the
table contest is coming up so I would
really encourage you all from beginners
to experience folks if you haven't
already thought about it to um
participate in the contest to submit
we're really Keen to look through
everything to share everything so you
could learn about
uh building great you know interactive
great data display tables and the
community can share from your your work
as well
cool so allow me to introduce Greg
um so yeah first and foremost questions
comments uh please use the slider link
there the posit slash OS chat uh and
introducing Greg
howdy Greg hello hey Curtis
thank you for joining us oh thank you so
much it's so it's so interesting because
I don't you know we're not on Zoom
anymore so I can't actually ask people
if they've been following yeah so it's
very much a kind of open question as to
how well those go
um yeah so uh first and foremost
um
the reactable uh on the reactable
package one thing I noticed for the
actual package I don't think it has a
hex yet why is there no hex
X um well
if I don't really care about hex logos
so if you really want to you can buy
some empty heck stickers off of um
Amazon or wherever draw your own and
feel free to use that
at the conference there's actually like
um
like blank stickers that you could draw
your your own hex and I can come to the
next conference pick one of those up and
do it yourself otherwise that's what you
really care about
um next logos yeah
um yeah didn't you because the reactable
formatter by Kyle and Mr NASA's last
name but coolia has a hex has a hex
already yeah
um okay so serious questions uh now uh
and we're starting to get a few from the
audience
um but we'll get to those in a moment
um so you started working on reactable
and uh yeah I guess the summer of 2019
can you kind of talk through that
initial like idea and where it came from
yeah sure so and also with my
description was my my setup for
reactable accurate like would you add
anything else to that or
um yeah so um
reactable started
can I started at the r Studio conference
in 2019 like you mentioned with the the
reactor package there's a talk there by
Alan diapers um he was working with Ken
Russell on this package called react art
that
allowed you to
more easily integrate react JavaScript
libraries into R and like the HTML
widgets ecosystem
and they're just a whole bunch of
JavaScript libraries out there that's
um really powerful like database
libraries
they're all in all in uh written by
written in reacts and that's like that
was the
um the booming web framework around that
time it still is super popular
and that just allowed you to
more easily integrate those libraries
into Arc instead of having to like write
a manual wrapper around a JavaScript
library which is kind of painful
and I want to try that out too since I
thought thought the talk was really cool
and so
um
a bit after that conference I was just
looking for
libraries to the tryouts
um reactable was not actually started to
create a data table Library I just
arbitrarily picked a data table because
it's a useful thing it's probably
in every app I create there's going to
be a data table so I was using DT a lot
DT is probably still like the most
uh common
HTML Widgets or a library that I go for
when I'm making shiny apps or whatever
or markdown Docs
and so I picks this Library called react
table
it was just a table Library
um there there's a whole bunch of them
um I picked this one pretty arbitrarily
but I think it turned out pretty well
because
it had a lot of uh provide a lot of
flexibility features and
there's some things in there that were
some features in there that like weren't
as easy to do in the data tables Library
like
um
nested Rose good throws in
in data tables world it's kind of a kind
of a hard thing to do nested rows and
react table made that easier so I
thought why not just pick this one out
to try it out and it just started as
like
uh an experiments it still is in
experiments most but the primary goal of
just experimenting and trying out
um reactor
and and I guess
every every couple days I'll work on and
then just
uh became a a real package instead of
just like a little toy
yeah now it's either the number two or
three table package in our I feel I see
it all over the place you know on Tiny
Tuesdays and it's used throughout
people's work
um so yeah it's an amazing contribution
after a few years of development
um
another question I'd warned you about
this too so this is kind of like more in
the setup realm of things
um can you kind of tell me why open
source so you you work on the package
manager team which is one of our
professional products not not so much
open source there are open source
elements in packet manager but
um you know why why are you working for
an open source software company why why
is it important to you
uh open source
so I think
my own reason for um why open source is
important is that you know I've learned
so much from open source
like uh and I'll probably as much as
I've learned about software and
programming from just being a
professional software developer just
reading open source code and I'm using
open source libraries
I think the the learning part is really
important like there's so much high
quality code out there and software that
you can
look at learn from adopt
um and interview back to you and so I
think open source is really awesome in
that aspect
um
well also like
at a posits or rcdo our products use a
lot of open source and
um in Million past years a lot of people
some people have said that open source
isn't open source software isn't as high
quality as like closed Source software
and I've heard that in person too but if
you look at all our
all the professional products all the
closed Source Products out there
um even a bunch of
the closed Source Products at posits
most of our software
or actually all of our software
is using a ton of Open Source libraries
and components underneath and we don't
think it's
uh low quality I think it's as high
quality as any other software out there
well um I guess as an end user uh why
why should I can strongly consider an
open source set of tooling rather than
some sort of closed Source tooling that
uh you know maybe my employer is kind of
pointing me to that sort of thing like
what would you what would be your pitch
for uh trying to consider the open
source alternative to getting your work
done okay um well as a user
um it's free
uh that's that's my number one reason
it's it's uh
yeah it's free it doesn't cost like
thousands of dollars
um
but also still also the
what I what I said about um
open source software being as high
quality as any software
um
it's just not
I mean of course there's some closed
Source software that's that uh that just
doesn't exist in the open source world
and so of course you do have to use uh
closed Source software sometimes but if
you can reach for an available open
source Library component then
um why not and then also there's also
the
nice aspect about
um contribution back and
being able to
file bug reports or ask for feature
requests on
like their open issue tracker some
closed Source Products don't really have
like a direct
path for feedback back
into the
the products
you kind of like sometimes you have to
yell out on Twitter or send them emails
or something I don't know
does that answer your question
yeah yeah and sorry I should apologize
again to start with sort of high-end
philosophical glance but it's it's
definitely the thread that kind of
connects these OS chats together so yeah
I really appreciate it
um so kind of Shifting texts a little
bit
um changing tax a little bit we have uh
a couple demos that you had set up uh
and then there's a few questions that
have kind of come in through chat so I
feel we might as well just dive into a
couple of the questions some are some
are Technical and some are less so so
I'll just kind of jump in let's just
kind of work through each one of those
uh and once we've kind of gone through
those we'll shift to demos and hopefully
a couple more questions have come up out
of that or something so um the the first
one is uh
um yeah it's it's GitHub issue number
one what's the ATA on editable
reactable editable tables okay
also okay so look at looking at um
edible tables I guess there are two ways
to kind of answer this the first is a um
edible tables are technically possible
right now
um a while back there's like a a table
contest submission for DT where
you could edit it's not it wasn't using
the it was a an editable table example
but it wasn't using the built-in editing
features of DT you had like um
a table with like an edit button where
you click the edit button and it showed
a modal where you can edit the data in
shiny and you can also do that in
reactable I just haven't
gone around to making a public demo of
that but it is possible maybe after this
I'll go finish up that example and put
it up on
the website somewhere
but you could also look at this as an
opportunity to maybe call upon the
community to help you with that example
yeah not to make you do anything but
like and then the
so what they and then the other side of
it's um what the issue was originally
talking about and what I should probably
post on that issue instead is that
editable tables as in like an Excel
based data grid kind of thing just
I don't think that's ever going to
happen in reactable and part of that is
because
um that kind of
uh components like a data grid is
technically different from the table
like um in an Excel grid like you have
every cell that's edible you can
navigate around with arrow keys and
um it's it's technically it's considered
more of like a grid rather than a table
in
HTML the HTML semantics and like
assistive Technologies and Screen
readers and
um just the way you use it it's totally
different so
well it could be implemented in
reactable I just don't think
it really makes sense I mean it might be
like a separate package that kind of
shares the same stuff enters as
reactable but for now I don't think
that's going to happen it's also a
really hard thing to do there's so many
um so many different
challenges with it that I just don't
have time for it and
uh I'm sorry
that's great
um I'm gonna jump into some of the kind
of technical questions that have
appeared in chat
um if I'm completely honest I don't
fully understand this question but we'll
see see how we go so Patrick is asking
um uh update reactable does not allow
for JS style direct manipulation of the
Dom
um the the data is loaded new
do you do you follow that context he had
a he had kind of a second chat question
which I can maybe show
so okay the the second part was
registering custom JS function on
reactable does not work with uh one uh
session on flushed and then two in the
uh with tag style because when the table
is rendered later the JS is not
registered do you follow that or would
that maybe be a better question posed on
GitHub issues yeah definitely definitely
post that on on GitHub and um it'll be
easier to think about let's play
is uh gonna get into like the weeds a
bit and I I don't totally understand it
as well but the first question I think
might be
answered by one of the demos
um you're asking about
update reactable
it's like reloading the entire table or
something like that
so I should apologize to Patrick then
um we could we could follow with this
kind of after the event uh you know I
think a GitHub issue would probably be
the the ideal place to do that
um another question uh from a different
person from uh I'm gonna mispronounce
but ardee um hi first thing I wanted to
say that's nice to have opportunity to
chat with you
um for Greg developing this package
since we can't be found on Twitter so
this is another core thing uh in fact
one of the advantages you mentioned of
Open Source software is that oftentimes
reaching out to the maintainer is kind
of a bit easier so I I I'm curious like
you know if people do want to reach out
to say thanks or to offer bug reports or
feature requests that sort of thing yeah
what are your ideal what are your
preferred ways for people to reach out
to you
yeah offers thanks for the comments and
um I think the best
the best way to reach out is probably
on GitHub GitHub issues
um I kind of treats the issues is like a
general discussion forum so you're free
to ask questions
or open Bug reports of course ask for
features
and then if you
if you really want to if you really
don't want to use GitHub issues
uh there have actually been people that
emailed me you can find the you can find
my email from
the description file
um if you really want to do that no
Twitter for me though I don't have time
for Twitter
um perfect uh and then in chat folks
just shared the link to um to the GitHub
issues by the way uh which I'll if
you're watching this after the recording
is live you know if you're watching it
on on YouTube well after the Live Events
uh it'll be in the description as well
um there's a question from sort of a
question from from Michelle
um I've mocked up python data frames
with reactable but I cannot cannot seem
to create arbitrary number of stacked
column headers to mock hierarchy
hierarchical columns multi-index which
is not exist in our data frames
um I know that there's like a lot of a
lot of like context on top of that so
yeah I'm curious if you if you do have a
reaction or or is this maybe something
that's like a kind of a feature request
type thing
yeah so I'm not uh
I'm gonna need to see a picture um
Michelle if you can draw a picture and
uh follow feature request on GitHub that
would help otherwise
I don't really understand
uh what this exactly means but
complex
headers and um in tables are just going
to be
a challenge and a pain so
um
this is interesting in terms of format
um you can kind of see the strengths of
more of a zoom or more interactive
format that's just an aside for future
ones I I am taking that into account
um but yeah broadly are you considering
kind of a python package or better
support for python uh people working
with python
uh
might be able to answer some of this
from when the first demo maybe and then
for first class python supports it is
definitely possible the the core library
of reactable is all JavaScript and so
you can wrap JavaScript libraries in any
other language sure we could have a
python
uh ipy Widgets or whatever you're using
now I'm not really that familiar with
the python ecosystem but
definitely gotta take a look at shiny
for python soon and
um the Jupiter side of which it's maybe
eventually down down the road just need
time
but also uh check out the first demo
that's
I'll have
isn't that demo available right now like
something we could link to
um
oh sorry the first demo today I'm sorry
yeah
is that the quarto plus observable or
which is the title of that one yeah
perfect give me one second I'll actually
set it up for you
um so this is demo one and I'll have the
link links a little long but I'll have
the link in there as well maybe one
moment
cool so the yeah
um that's awesome there are a few more
questions that we'll get to you and
again feel free to pose your questions
either in chat or at this link here uh
pause it so POS dot it slash chats and
we'll get to those in a moment
um and for the the demo yeah this is
perfect so I'll hide myself okay
okay so the good news about
um
they can use about the pythons where is
that if you're doing this static docs
you can use the awesome new quarto
to connect different languages you can
do your data managing in Python and then
um
build some Interactive
UI inputs with observable and then
visualize those that filter data from
python in in ours uh reactable package
so here's just a simple demo of using
observable with reactable and equipto
dock this was made literally yesterday
so it's still work in progress and also
it used some new features in the
unreleased development version of
reactable so if you want to check this
out then
you do have to install the package from
GitHub for now but here's a preview of
what's
should eventually be possible
so here's an example of
I'm using observable inputs to
filter a reactable table
you got the
um the slider this is the Penguins
Palmer penguin data sets it's one of the
examples from the quartet websites
you can use the slider from observable
to filter tables
you can subsets the data frame
it's basically like
the same example from same same Penguins
example from the Corto side set instead
of an observable
um table I think it's called We're
showing a reactable table instead
and the code for that's
the code to hook up observable with
reactable is
just one line it's using the
um this new method in the JavaScript API
where you can update a reactable tables
data using a JavaScript call alone
and so
here this is just an observable cell
and the user will sell we're filtering
the data
from um the the Penguins data sets and
then anytime the data is filtered
we're also updating the reactable table
data with the filter data
and it's
hooked up to observable
and then we can also do it the other way
around where you can use a
reactable table to filter unobservable
charts and let me see
for whatever reason the Applause isn't
showing up
I think I have to refresh
okay
so instead like a slider input in
checkboxes I have a table here this is a
reactable table with a couple custom
filters
and then this plot down here is not made
by R but it's
um one of the D3 no or no observable
plots
um
a plot plots plotting thing and body
mass by section species
so we can use the reactable table to
filter and the plot automatically
updates
could we get our GD plot in there or is
that is that something to be highly
customizable ggplot let's see
um
I think GT plus are static so
you might have to use shiny for that I
haven't played around with the
the Corto shiny integration but it's
probably possible you just need a
oh you might need a server and our our
server behind the scenes
um
maybe you could use GT plotly I'm not
sure
what about for
um there's a question from uh Uriel
um asking about uh for for nested tables
I guess for you know like collapsed
versions or nested tables does that work
as well
NASA tables
um
you mean to updates then that's the
table
like I believe so yeah
uh I think so I think that would work
you just need um internet table
you will need to
add an ID to that table so you can
identify it
and it should work although
that's the tables have always been kind
of
um
uh
study buggy or you might if you if you
Clap the table it'll reset the state so
it might be a little wonky but um
I think it would work
you can try it out
maybe another good user demo one one
thing I've appreciated as I've been
doing research for this is the community
does a lot of development on their own
and it'd be good to see some experiments
with that to see how well it works
um I think you just answered this
question but but Mike um also is asking
about yeah so if uh GTE table here you
know getting updated with with the uh
with the filter and the sliders you know
is maybe a little tricky what about
plotly I think you just said that that
conceivably would would work but yeah
what do you think yeah so plotly
probably the same
uh if you're using poly from R then
probably a similar answer to
um
the ggplot or gt plot the answer
it might be a little trickier
so that
the whole point of doing this or the
whole planet is demo is that the this
plot is using
observables plotting Library
so I forgot to show the code but
it looks like this
looks like this
this is a a built-in library in an
observable so you can just use out of
the box and it just works
and so if you're
using plally from from R then it might
be a little bit trickier to set up
you can do with poly if you use
crosstalk yeah that's that'll probably
work
um
hooking up crosstalk to
the observable inputs might be a little
trickier
but
it's probably possible and then if
you're using poly from like the
JavaScript library the JavaScript
wrapper then it might be a little easier
I don't know I haven't I haven't tried
that out much it's uh definitely good
interesting thing to
um test out if you want to
awesome
um so just to recap this uh we shared
the link in in the video description
we're also be sure to have a link to
this demo as well as your other demos
um yeah I'll jump into the next question
um I'm gonna show it here and then hide
this
um before we jump to this question I
should remind folks you know feel free
to ask questions outside oh there's a
couple more that I'll get to there or
post questions on chat
um I was curious you know for for users
of of reactable and maybe even people
looking to contribute in one way or
another
um and kind of guide your development
roadmap
um yeah what is an element look look
like uh you know what is what is being
worked on now
so the development robot
is not very concrete it's uh there's not
really a development roadmap is because
this is a
um
free time projects for fun and so I just
work on it whenever I want to whenever I
feel like it and don't worry that much
planned for kind of deal just um
there's some things like General
features issues that I have in mind but
no real roadmap but what's currently
being worked on now is a really popular
feature request in the past um
server-side data processing so that's
something that's been missing and
reactable for a long time
if the assets uh
that's actually part of why it hasn't
been added to reactable because DT
server side data sport is just
uh it's there and it works really well
so
that's that's what I've been using for
server-side data myself
and
service side data is also kind of hard
to do it's at least a lot of efforts but
um
I actually do have some time to we're
gonna now
um mostly being sponsored by posits
they're giving you like some time at
work to work on it and so right now it's
I wouldn't say it's coming soon but at
least soon there should be at least a
working branch that you might be able to
experiment with
um
yeah so there's server-side data
processing I can show a demo of that in
a bit
um a bunch of JavaScript API
enhancements like we want to just showed
with a quarter and observable there's a
whole lot more that you can do with the
JavaScript API where you can manipulate
a reactable table just like it could
with like shiny but without having a
server in the background
it's all in your browser you can do
basically create an interactive app kind
of like
observable all
from R and JavaScript
so there's actually a quick question we
can answer uh from chat and then if
you'd like I'd love to dive into your
demo for the JavaScript API
um the question is from Lionel asking
about adding sparklines to reactable
um I I should mention because I could
sort of answer that as well there's a
really nice package that Kyle uh culeo
I'm going to mispronounce the name
Coolio Coolio has a
um in the packages reactable formatter
which is reactable
um fmtr and has a really nice
integration with sparklines and I was
kind of curious yeah what your advice
would be as well yeah you can use
reactive formatter to do sparklines I
think that's using the data UI package
that Arthur Shaw mentioned
um there's also the the classic
sparkline package it's a kind of an
order
HTML widget package but if you go on to
the through the documentation websites
if you let me pull that up
um
you go on the website you go to the
examples page
uh
makes it somewhere interesting
okay
so in the the customer custom rendering
section of the
examples page there is
example called embedding HTML widgets
and this uses the
sparkline package that you can install
from Cran
and it's got like really simple
sparklines box plots
bar graphs
and usage is just like
you call sparkline on your
um on your data and then
give it a type if you wanted something
other than like the classic sparkline
and then a posit BBC posted a
that does the table example table
contest example with
doing sparklines with reactable
formatter
there's a question
um is there some sort of reactable verse
yet that I I I'm not sure exactly how to
interpret these questions but it's you
know um our Arthur was sort of asking
our sparklines are there any maintained
packages that help I'm not sure exactly
what that means because you know uh Kyle
is maintaining the reactable formatter
package
um yeah so yeah if you could kind of
dive into that
yeah I have uh I have no idea other than
reactable formatter
I think
if there is one then
um Kyle probably started it with
reactable formatter but um
hey that's like a
up let's use that as like a call to
actions to the community if you want to
um extend reactable because reactable is
definitely made and designed for
extensibility like it's really just a
simple data table library that lets you
render custom HTML custom contents it
doesn't actually do sparklines or any of
this other fancy bar graph bar chart
stuff that's all
those are all examples in the
documentation
and if you see like a lot of the code is
kind of just
if you want to use it then you you can
copy paste it from the examples but
if there are other libraries that make
it easier to
or save you from having the copy paste
example then that's really nice but um
yeah I don't know if any other packages
besides reactable formatter although you
can use other if you look through the
examples there are all sorts of
um packages that help out with creating
tables particularly like dataviz kind of
tables
um they're packages for formatting data
um
doing stuff like tool tips you can use
any of the HTML widgets packages
and reactable
reactables Custom
HTML rendering stuff
so I mean this is kind of related to
that question it's really not so much a
question for you but a question to the
the broader Community suppose suppose I
am an art developer and and you know
some of this JavaScript stuff is a
little is a little Beyond me
um but but there's some functionality I
would really like but it's sort of not
doesn't exist yet or it's not well
documented you know maybe there's a
stack Overflow posts that kind of like
describes how you should approach it but
you know you're just you're just not
kind of there yet in terms of your
ability to kind of pull it off
um so again it's not so much a question
for you because you're kind of like well
you're well advanced in terms of your
ability
um but what would you suggest to these
kind of our users to like to to kind of
turn I guess it's sort of turning to the
open source Community to get their help
to to kind of pull these things off to
get those examples developed so that
more people could kind of pull in these
these additional features that they
really want to like really you know make
make the table that they really want to
make
um so I think
probably the best
um best way to get started is just look
through examples
um
especially like the the simpler examples
you can start from there and then tweak
it to however you like and kind of learn
from there
um definitely you can also use like the
the reactable formatter package to
simplify some of that
um oh I don't know about I don't know
how much the reactable formatter package
does with custom JavaScript but at least
with custom r
custom R rendering um it helps a lot
there
for for JavaScript
that's kind of like more on the advanced
side and for the reactive package I've
tried to make it
possible where you don't need to use
JavaScript of course
um in custom rendering
you can write your
Custom Custom cells all in R we just
stick to the the shiny HTML tools HTML
widgets uh ecosystem you can do it on or
if you want to but if you do want to
uh make your tables fancier and flashier
with JavaScript
then
uh they're all they're a bunch of
resources
for
learning and getting started with
JavaScript
I guess I would always reckon I always
recommend the
Mozilla docs the mdn docs we just type
in mdn in Google
then you'll find them
those are great resources for learning
about just
General HTML JavaScript and CSS
awesome and you also had set up a demo
diving into a JavaScript API would you
like to dive into that sure
so
we very I've already talked about the
the JavaScript API bit but this is the
this is a feature that's already in the
release version on Cran
like I said it helps you make
helps you manipulate tables and make
like custom interactive controls without
the use of shiny and also without the
use of crosstalk so crosstalk is also
really nice
if we had more time we could probably
look at crosstalk examples but
um a lot of people might already be
familiar with crosstalk
but the thing with crosstalk is that
it's kind of limited to what it can do
and of course doesn't
help you
um do fancy stuff with like very
specific packages like
um like sorting a table
so
uh first example in the JavaScript API
docs you just if you want to go to the
examples page scroll down all the way to
the end
there's a couple examples with the
JavaScript API and then
in the Articles there's also like a
a more detailed guide on how to use the
JavaScript API
so the first example here is a CSV
download button is that yet sorry this
is a um really popular feature requests
making a download button for like a
table
without the use of shiny you could
definitely do it in a shine yet but if
you're like you got our markdown
documents for a cultural document then
it wasn't really possible before but now
you can use the JavaScript API to
um
download uh data to a CSV file
and it's just one line code here it's
not like it's not like built-in the
nicest built-in creation like you have
with DTS one fdt's um download button
extensions but it isn't too bad to
implement your own button this is a
download button in four lines of code
uh you can click it and it'll download
the data to CSV
and then there are other things like um
doing custom filtering with the
JavaScript API
this example has a
custom column filter that's completely
external to the table so is this select
input here it's not a table at all it's
outside the table and it filters
the table by um
by type of car
and then you can
also build your own custom search inputs
using a similar thing
along with custom column filtering you
can do custom table filtering
this is also a
external filter input outside table
you can do the same thing
search for
a pen and it'll filter cable
you can do yeah
[Music]
go ahead sorry I think are you still
there's still more JavaScript API
examples sorry
okay um yeah
let's go to these
I've never been taught more
this one is a programmatic grouping
example
so there's no way to uh
do this interactively from the table but
you can now create your own grouping
inputs
so you can it's basically like an
interactive pivot table
by whatever then you'll have these um
group rows that you can expand
you can look at the data in different
ways
[Music]
um
yeah before you couldn't really control
this on the fly all you had all you had
to do with um or all that was possible
was
just grouping up fronts and you couldn't
change that in
on the page after the table loads
and here's another
example of
creating a button that expands all rows
on the table
so
these are just a couple examples
um
you can take a look at the the
JavaScript API guide for more details
and more information on usage it will
probably be more examples in the future
too
yeah you had mentioned you had another
demo focused on custom Advanced
filtering I think that's a separate
article right yeah that's that's I know
there's many popular features but I know
in particular that was a very popular
feature yeah
um we can go through real quick this
also related to the JavaScript API
um
another popular feature request has been
like custom filtering Advanced filtering
range filtering right now it's only for
it historically it's only been possible
to
do the little text inputs text search
which is really simple
um range filtering is particularly
complicated but you can now at least
create your own custom filter inputs and
custom filter methods and logic like
instead of the
the case and sensitive text search right
now you can do a reject search or you
can do like a numeric minimum value
search or
fuzzy text search so
there's an example or this article is
under Articles custom filtering
and if you go down to examples you can
see
a little of what's possible
I'll just go through like the
a couple examples here
like for example if you want to do
regular expression filtering instead of
the plain text search you could do that
if you want to with a custom filter
method
um and this does require you to know
some JavaScript so it's not the easiest
to use but at least we're going to start
here making it possible to do custom
filtering and then maybe later there
will be like built-in
ways to
um select different filter methods and
different filter inputs so here's like a
regular Expressions try out
regular question and I think that works
um this example is fuzzy text searching
and it uses an external Javascript
Library
that lets you do fuzzy text matching
so here
I've added a fuzzy text search the
default search inputs you can search for
something like
CDL and it'll match Cadillac
so this definitely is not possible with
the default table but you can do
um
you can basically
typo whatever you want then you'll still
search for
it we'll still get the
um result that you probably wanted to
see
uh I showed some of this
the Corto demo but you can also do like
a select input search
and search by
um
categorical values or vectors
this already exists on DT but it's just
a little harder to do and reactable
right now
um this example is
a custom data list filter
so a daily list is like a it's a native
HTML input that lets you
have it's like a hybrid between a text
attracts input and an autocomplete
so see it auto completes what you typed
here and then they'll search just like a
select input
this is the range filter example
I think I I showed this earlier too but
you can now do a range filter if you
want to it's just a little
uh
just a little effort to make this happen
but it is possible now since in this
example searches for a minimum value
and then
see
and you can put your your range filter
outside the table if you want to
all using the JavaScript API
you can do check boxes or whatever other
type of input you want
this example
I think it's it's like a filter to
um
filter table by rows that have missing
values
and there's a bunch of other examples
but I'll skip it for now
yeah I was good I was going to mention
there's actually uh you'd prepared a few
demos for us and I I don't think we're
gonna have time to get through yeah
but if you also I'll I'll put all the
Demos in the in the video description so
for people who are watching this
afterwards I'll put into the video
description a link to all the demos that
you wanted to get through today and in
particular I'll put timestamps
associated with ones you have gone
through today
um looking at your pattern it does look
like they're pretty much they're they're
all the reactable Articles or new
sections within articles that have
already existed like the examples for
example so yeah it's a lot of material
there just in in your package
documentation and um there was a couple
of nice compliments about how good your
documentation is so side note there
um one question related to some of the
stuff we're talking about before I think
yeah so yeah Arthur was asking just to
add to Mike's question about reactable
verse what would you what would be the
best and most logical way for the
community to add reactable functionality
for example more custom reactable
extensions that sort of thing
yeah so I think
um
by the
or I guess it depends on
where in the reactable
uh the stack that you're adding one egg
functionality like if you want to add
like custom formatters or renders or a
rendering helpers like kind of like
reactable formatter then uh a separate
package definitely makes sense
you can
create functions that like other people
can plug into their own reactable tables
um you can create different table themes
that people can put into your tables
as for like core
uh table functionality
um
that'll probably have to mostly go in
the react tool package
so you can I guess I would recommend
starting out like a good issue to talk
about
um
we're thinking about adding and then
we can figure out where to go from there
like whether it makes sense to open the
pull request and reactable or if it
makes sense to contribute something to
the reactable JavaScript library
um
yeah
cool and then kind of one underlying
theme of some kind of comments and
questions was I'm going to kind of
reinterpret things a little bit so
apologies to folks who did ask you know
kind of more specific stuff but some of
the questions were sort of like there's
reactable but there's Alternatives
there's DT there's R oh sorry there's
there's GT
um and so they're they're flexible
they're flexible yeah there's there's
many many others actually
um so yeah if you could kind of compare
reactable with other popular packages
like GT and R uh and kind of relating to
this to uh I mean it's it just
tangentially related you know Mike had
asked this question just now like you
know what would be the differences
between reactable and DT that you would
kind of point out you've already said a
few areas use cases where I might choose
one over the other
um and I sort of bring up that question
because there's also GT which is under
active development uh supported by posit
as well so how do you think about that
yeah like kind of there's a lot of
overlapping functionality but you know
sometimes one is very strong in kind of
certain use cases that sort of thing so
how do you how do you think about that
or approach that
so I might start with saying that um
I didn't
start this package to like create a
well I didn't intend intentionally
started this package to create like a
better data table Library
I was really just experimenting with the
reactor package and so
it wasn't meant to be like a replacement
or
an improvement over DT
and there are some features that I just
like that existed in DC that's I just
never wanted to add like server-side
data because it already exists
but um
in terms of reactable versus GT or other
uh most other data table packages
reactable is interactive and so it's a
whole lot different
um
doing interactive tables versus like
static HTML tables
um this this package is
mostly JavaScript driven by JavaScript
they're
got sorting filtering and pagination
grouping
nested tables a bunch of other stuff
um I just aren't possible with
static HTML
so I think the only real
similar table or a similar table library
is really DT
Maybe
uh
are Hands-On grade if you kind of want
to consider
like the data grid kind of thing a table
but I think it's really only similar to
DT
and as for reactable versus DT
I think there are a few
um
points we could
talk about but
for
maturity definitely DTA has been around
forever I think it's more stable
um definitely less breaking changes
reactable has probably been around for
like three years now but I still
consider it pretty new
just because
um I haven't spent a whole lot of time
working on it
um it's still kind of like in the
experimental phase I haven't bothered to
take off the experimental badge from the
readme
so if you want stability definitely
um stick with DT and data tables
um
we talk about styling I'm pretty sure
that the the most common reason for
picking up reactable versus DT is just
that it's easier to style uh reactable
because again in that data tables world
if you want to
customize like the default theme
you need to go to the data tables
websites use their custom CSS generator
and I've done that before it's a huge
pain that's kind of a thing with data
tables
that um
let's get this not very fun too we don't
need to customize them too much yeah but
like the react yeah reactable formatter
package the cloud made there's already I
think there's ESP there's already
built-in themes that you could then
extend too yeah it's pretty clear how
you could really make it look custom uh
the way you want it to look just with we
have a few minutes left before the turn
of the hour so I wanted to wind down
things and give you a chance to
um once again go over again
um so as people kind of have questions
or feedback or they want to contribute I
was curious if you could offer them ways
I'll give you the first way just to be a
little selfish again we have the table
contest going on right now
um whether you're a new user which we
have special prizes just for people who
are starting out developing an r in
general or an experienced user I really
encourage you to participate in the
table contest
um to share your work
um you know with the community to kind
of use as an as a motivation to just
kind of really dive into some of the
stuff and then you know there's prizes
involved there's celebration involved
and then a lot of the the kind of best
contributions are often invited into the
table Gallery which is a nice little
resource uh you know table Gallery is
basically here's a nice looking table or
collection of tables or tutorial and
then here's all the code and well
documented uh kind of narrative that
explains everything uh and it's all done
by the community uh celebrated you know
contributors to the community
um but yeah how would you you know what
kind of calls to action would you give
to the community uh in order to as you
as you're kind of Shifting over to
developing
um sorry when you shift over to develop
reactable
now definitely submit stuff through the
table contest that's it's always cool to
see those entries and I've seen some
really fancy stuff
um really nice nice stuff
um
open issues on the geta repo ask
questions asked for
submit feature requests or
um bug reports
and
um
I guess that's
those are my calls to actually any
feedback is helpful like even on the
documentation the the website that's not
specifically about reactable but
um all of it helps
and also uh I know we're out of time but
I do want to show real quick like 30
seconds the service type data demo
before we end
absolutely this is the only demo that
that you can't find on uh on the
internet so here's
prototype for a work in progress for
server-side data processing
um it's just like DT
DT server-side processing all the data
manipulation is done in R and shiny
instead of all in your browser so here's
a hundred thousand data 100 000 row data
table these are not 100 000 rows in your
browser which will just um you'll barf
so
you can patinate it's pretty fast
um
you can search it's pretty fast oh this
is a this is also uh she mentioned
this is a
a shiny app that's running on a
different
server though it's not on this laptop
um
and search for
I'm gonna do all the same stuff and it's
still pretty fast
and then if you want for fun we can go
to the 1 million row table so this is
like why you would use server side
rendering over client side over the
defaults
um you don't want us to blast your users
with a million rows of data and put all
that Network bandwidth and uh
break somebody's uh browser so here's a
million rows
pagination is still
really fast
enough
search filtering
it's still very fast this is this is all
these one million rows are all in memory
and the other server that I have
so it's not my laptop
I'm doing all the searching
during this
spring kind of lags a bit but I still
can see
not too bad as you probably know this
comes up a lot how do I deliver to my
user a big table kind of so but but I
know there's no link to this yet like so
so if I wanted imagine someone's
watching this in the future the
recording of it uh where where is this
example going to live to to learn more
about it
um I have no idea yet but hopefully
it'll be possible to find it from the
websites
um
it'll be a
pretty it should be a pretty important
feature so I'll make sure you can find
it
and for what it's worth um I recall the
table contest or maybe it was the shiny
contest if I'm confusing things I think
it had a couple examples of kind of
server size with like agitation yeah
yeah there's one one really awesome
example from um I can't remember the
name but they basically implemented
uh server-side data processing and
reactable even when it wasn't possible
so it was technically possible can I
possibly afford but
um they did it and the interesting thing
about that was that it was using data
that that was not in memory it wasn't
like a sqlite database and you could
also like pull data from a third-party
API and that will also be eventually
possible you can you will be able to
write your own custom back-ends to hook
it up hook up reactable to like postgres
or sqlite database or some third-party
API but it's coming down the line um
it's
probably not going to be available
immediately
it's also awesome example that was a
really cool
table content submission
well to winding things down thank you so
much
um for the folks who are sticking around
to the end as well thank you so much as
well
um this will be I mean I think it's
immediately uploaded to YouTube but I'll
probably edit things a little bit to
make sure the start of the stop have a
nice beginning and end and I'll make
sure the description is is kind of cut
up well with good appropriate timestamps
so if you wanted to skip to a particular
kind of set of content you'll be able to
um but I do want to mention to the few
people watching uh still now
um right this is a the second pilot of
the of the open source chats so I am
really Keen to hear your feedback on how
these are going
um and so if you have feedback on this
kind of Open Source chat as a format and
a thing that we'll be doing next year
please feel free to reach out to me I'm
at Curtis at positive.co or rcd.com so
uh and you can reach out to me on
LinkedIn and uh on Twitter I'm actually
economic Curtis as well so I'm
definitely Keen to hear your positive
and and constructive feedback uh for
kind of how to do these you know maybe
what other technology we should use to
help encourage discussion and sharing
and that sort of thing
um so with that thank you so much Greg
for doing this it was awesome uh we'll
share all this demo and all of your
other demos a year to arranged
um to highlight as well I really
appreciate it thank you so much for like
giving us an insight into how you made
reactable reality and how you're looking
to improve it in future
thanks for hosting this and thanks to
everyone for watching and also thanks to
all the people who have posted something
on GitHub
um everyone is oddly nice like every
GitHub
almost all of them come with like I
think you know so
uh yeah thanks
thanks a bunch toodaloo bye bye